alright should we go ahead and get
started I am your discussion leader for
today on this topic of how how we can
test or falsify theories the Frank and
Fritz is going to serve us my skype and
so why don't we get me
so I thought what I do is maybe start
off with a few general observations
about this this problem of how we try
how we go about trying to test test
theories and and maybe we'll just maybe
stop us talking about some of the the
challenges and so one of the so one of
the one of the one of the challenges in
testing theories is that while testing
theories requires doing an experiment
and those theorists don't have
experimental love so kind of acquires
teaming up teaming up with other
experimental labs and one of the
challenges in that is that oftentimes
experimentalists and theorists come from
different cultures sort of think about
the problems differently and
experimentalists have their own agenda
so it's not like you know there's a
source sitting there tapping their
fingers waiting for a theorist to come
along with suggests an experiment to
them and so trying to understand how to
get on the same page with an
experimentalist so you can actually have
a productive relationship in terms of
getting on board with a theory and
actually trying to do the right
experiments and test them is is a
non-trivial task often time to execute
that another challenge I think is that
is that there's many moving parts here
guess what I mean by that is that most
models most models oftentimes are only
addressing one part of the system so you
might like I don't waddle to be one but
the one is having a obvious
interconnection of 72 without limits and
other areas other layers of the cortex
with other layers within v1 and so forth
and so your model may be only adjusting
one part of it but one part of the
system so you know it's inherently
incomplete and so because of that it's
very hard to make precise precise very
specific projects
often times and it sort of enough state
your let's take a lot of this take a lot
of put a lot in after that and and the
other is that often times de because the
nature of experimental data we can only
make partial observations so you can't
really sort of get a whole complete
picture of everything going on the
system so the best all you can be able
to just get kind of get a sparse
sampling of the neurons in the system so
so that's sort of limits how specific I
think what can deal with these with
these predictions sometimes that's
another challenge and then the other is
this idea of trying to bring bring
theories down to earth so so often
Thompson theories live up in math land
and bringing them down and to sort of
like physical implementation of how
you're actually implemented with neural
circuits as a challenge so I wish you uh
Lafitte was here because she was talking
about a there are discussions about how
she she hates Mars three levels so Mars
three levels you know have this sort of
level of computational theory algorithm
representation and that implementation
an implementation is sort of relegated
to sort ups out on the sub like an
afterthought and oh yeah somehow you
have to implement all this and that's
just like a slight detail and I actually
think that's really um that's really a
fundamentally important issue this often
overlooked just in the process of doing
any kind of physical realization of the
system whether you're building in
electronics or you're trying to think
about how neurons are doing in the brain
it's not just an afterthought if I think
my own expensively fundamentally affects
the theory as well and it's so I think
that's an important part of sort of
trying to test these models and nothing
on its and I think it ought to serve it
all circuitry
okay so I'm Jose are kind of just things
I want to throw out and I also want to
mention a few opportunities out there
protesting
testing theories and one is this ngerous
neuroscience data sharing sharing
repository in neuroscience that first
summer has been instrumental
run is called CRC not stork so this is
basically a repository of many different
experimental labs have contributed their
data for modelers to look at and test
their theories on and another Atlas we
were just talking about today the data
based objectives talked about today the
Allen Allen grain out list as the sprain
Observatory in the brain Observatory now
has many of these datasets for the mouse
online where you can actually look at
calcium imaging and so forth of large
population neurons a response to many
different kinds of stimuli so is the
opportunity to kind of do experiments
post talk and so let's see that I don't
know if it's so I'm just gonna throw
those things out for now I know Nancy
want to say a few words about testing
models you undo that now maybe at the
beginning we're just kind of like maybe
get that out there so and then and then
we'll open the floor so kind of people
can think about things too so yeah so I
thought of this yesterday we were
talking about benchmarks for different
kinds of models so yeah I'd like to find
out about benchmarks I'd like to find
something that can help connecting the
modeling with brain problems so for
example yesterday I talked about some
abstract problems that it seems from
neuroscience papers are assault in the
brain things like winner-take-all for
focus at some kind of similarity
detection for comparisons some kind of
neural coding so what I would ask is
whether the neuroscientists would be
able to come up with a small catalogue
of typical small problems that modeling
people could study so I'm not thinking
of general problems like the vision
problem I mean nothing big like little
nuggets that you know here's a typical
little problem that keeps recurring and
say that's an abstract way because
that's the way that the the
theoreticians would be able to try to
study that so what would we do with with
this well of course the modeling people
could have fun we can design networks
itself and we can analyze the energy the
convergence time network size that kind
of thing but maybe eventually these
could be used to could be tested with
experiments the first thing I thought it
is but you can see if networks that look
like this appear somewhere in the brand
if you're doing connectomics kind of
testing but maybe there's other other
techniques that would let you see if the
behavior like that of these these toy
networks actually appears somewhere in
the brain so we can use lots of help
from neuroscience people on suggesting
ideas for specifically what problems we
might look at other things so instances
where composition appears or doesn't
appear or levels of abstraction who
might have up here this would be nice to
hear about mathematics like what Bruno
was talking about so this is presented
in terms of linear algebra but that's
kind of global so how could we cast that
you'd like to study how you could cast
that in terms of neuro based local
algorithms so I think that's about it
just some ideas for making connections
with the theories Thanks
anybody else has like general conceived
whether somebody has an answer to her
challenge right before she leaves if not
maybe somebody can address some problems
question I guess better group is what
are examples in which more complicated
computations like what an organism
actually need to do in solve the
division problem whatever actually are
broken down into smaller primitives
addresses nephew was discussing that are
actually performed at all the building
in a microbe I don't know examples like
maybe there's one of the stages about
ancestors I know you're doing PCA
in the sensory system but do we have
examples where an actual micro circuit
computation occurs locally anywhere in
isolation central pattern generators
there you go okay
they're to me they have two chapters of
discretion run with plasticity and month
without clusters be right she discussed
something about the city and certainly
must subtract how far one can go because
this technically where wants to know
theoretically analyze it with no kind of
really rigorous mathematics no it is
easier than right but many questions
that come to my mind know for example
like no emergence of sparse coding is
said something there precisely gets
involved that it really is its
aggression or can you formalize in such
a way that it's analytically tractable
than right which is I think one of the
predict one of the desirable aspects
right no for a program another example
for Eric would be a retinal circuitry
for Direction selectivity I don't think
anybody talking about this we think yeah
that's pretty well-defined
so mean this old when circuits already
right now by who buzzed it might write
the episode also the this types of oh
yeah the brain broken shuts canonical
circuits sorry sorry this was for the
buzz it for Direction selected oh maybe
I think invasion selectivity so so I
think them the model they described in
this book is for all inpatient setting
yeah so there were some kind of no nice
circuits right which did something and
hit sample of to be grounding that but
probably they were never analyzed no
analytically in this regard
there is also a way to incorporate some
ontology modern world statistics
precipitation is a specification that
they classify different concepts and
concepts can be lost portion of the
brain damage we can forget even a
politic bone concept and something that
we also over time generalize and make
some movement I think looking to the
brain all the way
some other portion of the tree some
other physical work and most of the time
maybe you can look at this do you think
that was all separate I mean I don't
understand I mean they also have to be
presumably implemented by neurons right
yeah what's the distinction I don't
understand
Thanks Indian so first children because
the concept would didn't appeal didn't
see
I think
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but we can basically I think what you're
getting at is that there are actually
disorders that have a very odd so so you
know people lose the ability to
recognize something name it for example
they can still deal with it all the
opposite and things like that
and so I agree with you it's probably
would be good to kind of monitor all
these things in order to get a handle of
what and how information is represented
but I think I mean most I mean all
computation I mean most computation
theories of the brain do not think of
such a flat representation everyone
thinks that you know there's kind of a
hierarchical structure in sensory you
know general models
so I think what got you here I think I
still talk about simple compensation
privileges so I think we have talked all
about working memory right now okay you
can design though this in a very
primitive way as something where fit
comes in and has to be maintained and
you know some other bits no prompter to
read out occasional I see section also
finite state machine I think which makes
a lot of sense right and so implementing
this and I think this would be probably
nice no interpolations between Oh kind
of complex this theory and something
which seems to make sense for brain
circuits right the working memory so
what would be the waste of that suppose
to do pattern completion if I understand
no Nancy's program nor she described
this in a very similar version of a
winner-take-all circuit less selecting a
leader among those input lines which are
on there but so it's extremely simple
like no see rotations no like it no
simple right now there is no
modification also in working memory if
you really know kind of reduce it
through the barest bones is simply nope
it comes in it has to stay there until
some other signal comes that you won't
say buried all right now this is I don't
think about now how the brain works I
think about primitive
right and then later others can then
build out of these primitives now
something which is known interesting
brain task force all right but just like
this concept of thinking about new
computation primitives like no sequined
run it produces a weight in Sandin
cognitive now we want to have something
which is small circuits can be realized
and then also which is not very
analytically tractable which is
something new which many things no don't
ready no one has to say also that I mean
of course in theoretical neuroscience
there has been a lot of this
phosphorylation of these computational
primitives for example content
addressable memory like a hopfield
network and the problem a little bit was
is you can define all these primitives
but it's like the parts of a car and you
just put them next to each other it
doesn't make a car so to some extent I
would also say we somehow didn't get too
far
I mean maybe it's a good idea to rethink
this idea of the primitives now that we
have actually models we can put together
and do something interesting in the
course of machine roaming but in the
past I would say this is thinking in
terms of these small computational
primitives as long I mean there was a
lot of law on one kind of hopeful type
of networks but none of this has
actually really led to a computer kind
of a machine learning algorithm that
really performs something that you know
people would blow people away so I mean
us also there is something to be said
against thinking in terms of or I mean
in other words it's not clear if you can
of course define all these computational
primitives and you can analyze them but
it doesn't make a driving car I think
also we probably have different ideas
for the computational primitives but I
wouldn't even know think of a hopfield
network ID as a computation primitive
it's a simple artificial Network
paradigm I don't see this as know
something know as a computational
primitive like I was saying no but
enough to see where look in computer
science I hope a book on algorithm
design right now
you have an addition multiplication
sorting us all right we need know this
kind of basic law but application has
not for brain perspective there the
question is whether this exists that but
Palmer I mean if I think of a hopfield
network is like a content addressable
memory and then it is a primitive right
so you can but then I think it becomes
really more interesting because outfit
network comes together that is really a
coding assumption how will the input is
in code and how you want to read it out
if you kind of know phrase it more is an
input-output behavior like input
completion also write Association or so
then I think it becomes more interesting
than right and then one cannot say we
did Li whether it's going somewhere or
not that right
I wonder what different primitive sleep
will have in mind in this room for brain
conversation
yeah I think it will be very interesting
and important to to get an agreement on
what an incentive analysis would include
that's generic enough that it would have
a good coverage for example for your
computational models reinforcement what
could be back propagate as a feedback
and in practical and practical computer
networks right now that there is a very
strong trend in the blockchain world to
handle smart contracts and to be the
smart contract is as kind of a this kind
of a practical reconnect instant
instances of a
validation it just right now it's kind
of black and white okay if you hate it
then we deposit the money if you don't
meet it then nothing happens it's it's
it's it's an atomic primitive but as as
the blockchain applications are
mushrooming all sorts of ideas in for
the applications then it becomes more
like a praying like evaluation of the
incentives and the criteria of
acceptance so if someone could come up
with some something that's simple but
generic enough and and that could be the
correctness of it could be validated and
efficiently implemented I think that
that that could be useful for a lot of
things in the community errors you mean
now in terms of a brain brain moment I'm
sorry
you mean really in terms of a brain it
seems to me it's it's it's it's a I do
see a strong similarity between between
the computational models daddario that
the presented in the last three days
here and and the blockchain is having
it's not a single direction is it's
actually it's diverging from a very
simplistic financial model to all sorts
of and that's fine even if you have
hundreds and thousands of
cryptocurrencies right now because it's
until I can buy it anymore
a question about Buddhist kind of
feasible with the feasible lines of
research in experimental will
independent so one big one is vision
people study the pilikia study vision
trade of the genetics so different in
mice something very well studied so
series that come up with explanation of
what they want us can probably be more
testable and series that come up with
the part of the brain look at the
general landscape there which things I
think this is coincidental I mean house
many other modalities of the brain also
models I think we hope now the fish
itself or the awesome neuroscience a
prominent mortality
so if somebody's wants to - just another
wolf I don't know decision-making about
similarity would that be s that's the
ball that's what do you mean by
similarity I don't know ability of some
kind of spider to recognize similar to
similar objects would that be testable
or something about one thing the way
that was and maybe this isn't possible
in my neuroscience community but how
well this data is puts is pointed out
and and if you if we had a catalog of
grounded observations about what that
data says it could be about low level
about firing rates or it can be a
behavioral level or it could be about
you know memory interference or any
number of things and we make it easier
for people to find testable
relationships between their theory and
these observations and except in the
literature that there are different
levels of testability you know there is
the quantitative I've matched the data
exactly and my spike trains look exactly
like you know the real data and then
there's the well you know when I shut
off stimulus this thing goes up and it
also goes up in the real world and
that's a you know correlation with an
observed effect whereas if it went down
they were anti-correlated that would be
negative for the theory you know so my
point is make it easier in terms of
bringing the observations closer to the
theory and making and being more
accepting of the level of
agreement between theoretical
predictions and me yeah but it's a how
how could you do that so bad I'm not
hiding the data in a way that there's no
noise maybe they're gonna be a taxonomy
of observations attention to data sense
you know where it's you to search over
what are statements about great spiking
and with a weak animals with okay now I
just have to tell it is exactly they'll
the difficulty starts already versus
stunned of just sharing data sets you
know if you can see very hard because
it's so hard to describe the context
that you need to understand the
recordings you know the experiment red
haired I'm using and so there is a big
there's really a lack of methods somehow
to describe because of course you know
that the behavioral context of an
experiment is as rich as behavior yeah
but so it's a lot of work to take there
Larry and to connect it to a testable
proven so you find something that it
that it shows and you could be published
paper right you don't have the ability
to look for all the things that might
support yeah it might be almost easier
to do that actually on the site of the
theories so I actually talked to Kevin
in the information and he said also you
know if you have a machine learning
system that recognizes missed digits
this is not how people recognize nice
digits but okay so we need to assess oh
there's also there's really an
experimental interface to understand to
what extent you know I am Ultimo had a
machine learning model that really
recognizes in history images is similar
or different to how people do it so in
other words it would be interesting if
there is a theory and say okay I have a
method to do to recognize Nathan is two
digits that you kind of put it up in a
way in a dollar you know in a dollar way
that people can run the model and almost
run behavior experiments with it so that
you can then really figure out how does
this cocktail to behave clickable place
for sure yeah enabling experimentalist
to try to match the observations are
currently making where the theories
output reflect the idea of like sort of
getting like a taxonomy of observations
because one of the things I've always
enjoy about talking with experimental is
is just learning the you guys I think
have a very intuitive way of
understanding these systems you've had
some experience in which experience
recording from different layers and you
know that like neurons in layer three
they typically fire like this or these
other neurons are kind of silent more
often or whatever and so you hear all
these stories often times from
experimentalist that you'll never find
in a textbook and it's just things you
know from all your experience and that
just blows me away sometime cuz I'll
come on marching you know initially with
this sort of textbook understanding and
I'll talk to someone who actually knows
all this stuff and you get a completely
different side of it and I think some
way of just whining all that down and
consolidating us somewhere with the
enormous Lee and I'm gonna add to that
that
texana means probably the wrong word
like okay hanging is probably a better
word great economy applies this massive
organization always known electric
well yeah by tagging is sort of like
every you know you put all the labels
you want on saying this is mine so I
again I think this is really an
important problem but it is a public
government we have tend to organize to
think about how to organize this time
that is really kind of question driven
that we don't just have an overhead of
law that no one looks about right
right so how can how can fear is an
experimental is really to actually great
in two phases how what's a way of
generating citations yeah that's right
that would be so that makes it both some
work right but you of course you want to
do it yeah exactly and although that
they generate citations you need to come
up with ways to describe these things
that people really look at this in spin
time is it
speaking of this time the sky burn live
expect actually when and crawled through
PubMed and created and sort of an
association graph between all these
different tags and have this idea of
Ottoman hypothesis generation sort of I
like triangle completion so here is like
an example if you have let's say
serotonin tank is late is heavily
associated with striatum and serotonin
tag is also heavily associated with
migraines then perhaps there's an
association between those two between
Australia and migrants and like yes this
diagram that shows like five thousand
citations between striatum and serotonin
and three thousand between migrants her
tongue only sixteen between the
completion for triangle but the
buildings and generate expertise for a
stick
what I'm even asking this question is
the alternative way to ask it what would
what would people imagine to be
productive ways for experimental ists
and theorists to work together and what
kinds of institutional changes what can
be supported for the kinds of
collaborations should be supported in
order to promote the kinds of
interactions between experimentalists
and theorists that one might imagine
like professor thousand suggesting if
that is the kind of the kind of
interaction they're talking about what
would what kinds of changes within the
community would promote that and more
generally what kind of community to be
imagined to be the most productive for
future progress so the only thing that
one just from my angle a few of the just
suggestions sound like here we got
theorists and experiments are really
separable so we're gonna make the data
free-floating we're gonna make it off in
this database and as summer is saying
that we use it all of all of its context
you don't in theory you don't need to
know any of that context how it was
actually produced or something
it was the owning out there and we can
deal with that that may or may not be
the way to for forward progress I think
that's what you were well I mean
traditionally the interaction between
theorists and experimentalists pairwise
so you would have one experimentalist
with sir
engagement theorists really up and they
would explain you know the experimenter
would then explain the data in all the
detail
tell the theorist needs and there's an
entire fundament mechanism build on that
model like the seal CNS program in NSF
this is how how how teams are formed
there it's direct collaborations and the
idea to set up this this repository of
data sets of just shared freely is if
you insist on this pairwise combination
as a lot of theorists who have no data
it's because they don't happen to know
an experiment right and so the idea is
the substance of the other the idea what
was in the idea now at NIH is I mean
data assets are getting bigger and
bigger and more more complicated to
understand even for the experimenters
who collected them right and so the idea
is really to have this this to have
these platforms where people just can
actually share the data and I think the
overwhelming problem is communication
there's a lot of opportunity for
experimentalists and computational equal
to get together we don't talk in the
same language I don't see anybody to try
to solve that problem I think I told
solve we're never going to have the
how do we solve that well do like what
would you like there is to do better and
what would should experiment tools to
better have some guide is about it but I
think that one of the problems for
Neuroscience one of the one of its
strengths or one of its problems is it
it brings people from all sorts of
different backgrounds from physics to
humanities and people that come into
neuroscience without a math background
are completely tuned out all the
computational process it's very
difficult for them to learn this I
believe it's much easier for people with
their strong math background to learn
biology than the other way around
and I think that sorry yeah well I mean
I think biology is all about
memorization it doesn't require any
great intellect but I think that that's
harder frankly I think the onus is on
the computational people because it's
not going to work the other way around
you I find that computational people I
mean this is a criticism but they tend
to talk to each other biologist so I
know that they'll be Alec and Princeton
a number of years ago they were sort of
revamping their curriculum in the
biological sciences to really kind of
train people and much more in a
mathematical way because it's like
comparing to physics you know
theoretical physics force experimental
physics you know they both have the same
training the same basic training and
they can speak the same language then
about experiments that we don't we're
sort of that's what we're lacking and I
don't know what's become of that at
Princeton or maybe the present people
know about that curriculum but but that
seems like you know you sort of have to
start from that level it seems but the
next with a new generation of students
and retrain them in a different that may
well hey the answer that is happening in
a lot of places this is happening I mean
you know someone calls it both me
they'll be also cool
teach people with math background and
people with neuroscience background to
beta in this works very well in its
usual it's true that usually for the
quantitative people it's easier to catch
up to understanding the data because we
can from my case what was happening with
experimental is expensive you can use to
validate or define later think about
quantitative experiments is very easy to
be aligned switch to God's right it's
very easy to ask a question you have
this mop or did they have to secure the
Trinitite multisig it right and then
what do you do with it it's a paper but
as a model of the test we're modeling an
experiment is one big experiment you can
only rule half of series experiment
right and what we want to do is we want
to have experiments which have
significant digits are just about right
and many other surgical actually did
parameters with models and so on support
it is really I think that it's not the
issue of us not working to experiments
it's just the type of experiments are
most than this in my own medical school
as I said they don't have a need to talk
to me and I don't have to talk to them
because the experiments about using but
happy visit not up to you to convince
the experimentalist that do the
experiments and unifying you can argue
for that they are value for myself at
least I've decided that I am I'm not
necessarily willing to convince spending
my time of convincing people that I am
often but sometimes in the situation is
at the front doesn't get funded because
there is no theoretical analysis and
they start looking out for us right
it's a break asymmetric situation in
some sense and I can leave without down
on society as they can
I don't seem that very reason for me to
convince and science progresses all the
time so what are you but I guess this
depends on individual situations we have
our the studios yep a real collaboration
within this university I don't know how
many people are still here from the AI
side
today's question wondering you know is
there interest is there kind of
incentive to have more interruptions we
have people from neuroscience and
machine learning
you've saw in other areas we from the
machine learning side is there interest
from that sides bidirectional
whatever to say is that I think is
related to various and the discussion
will be very hard to imagine having the
theoretical models of data if you don't
have a frame and it's hard to imagine to
have a framework if I was thinking that
you know imagine 17th century and your
Newton and imagine you have data
molecular data at that time so without
even having a framework having a simple
Newtonian mechanics then I think physics
wouldn't happy Bob wouldn't have you
wouldn't have much you wouldn't have
made much improvement you had too much
if you had a lot of data I think part I
mean I don't have a solution but part of
the problem I think is neuroscience you
have just data just data at every scale
and you know it's just it's hard to
tease through is also related to looking
for simple computational primitives
force having simple computational
primitives we need perhaps filter this
experimental data in some sense and
using the word filter with the
equitation I don't have a solution but
it would be I'm afraid what is it what
kind of frame box exactly I mean for
having a frame obviously the framework
needs to match experiments but you
cannot have a framework if you want to
analyze everything in the experiments I
think I think I mean if evolve gradually
you know you have Newtonian mechanics
and based on that you build quantum
mechanics you know yes you know it's a
continuation but you cannot just build
quantum mechanics problems from the
start it's just impossible
yeah
oh well yeah so I'm on that Dai side
very much not a neuroscientist but I
know I one institution that's that
struck me is one one particular
institutional set up and you could start
being so having a lot of potential you
know something that I could be helpful
with all right so so you know what would
you know for example from the AI side
what would it take for me you know for
me to be useful in for know you more
productive and working with experimental
this right be you know
being able scale up to more naturalistic
tasks and being able to interact more
directly with experiments so I have some
friends who are in Princeton right in
their groups in Princeton this is just
one particular experimental setup that
struck me as useful right so there's
pretty nephal Kent enormous like
Princeton has a rat farm which is sort
of like a you know big server farm with
rats and shoeboxes electrodes and shop
floors and you know water bottles and
levers and such right and there are
other groups that have similar so I
think you know there's a lot of there's
also a lot of good work on the cognitive
side cognitive neuroscience site at
Princeton okay compute if you can build
institutions around things like that
right where you know someone someone
like me can interact more directly with
with an experimental set up that admits
experiments closer to you know the kinds
of things that I guess right yeah so do
they happen so can you a doctor there so
you well I guess you know what is
missing or what put them you know what
is there that you can actually really
directly in diet because I think it's a
it's a complicated communication problem
I think the other scientists also should
communicate to you guys yeah yeah so one
you know pretty you know for something
like that to be say more fully you know
more fully formed as a certain point
collaboration right that it might be you
know perhaps did the experimental West
Point for example you know in addition
to sorry I don't I don't think bring
that forward that that it's possible to
say provide like you know rats in the
cloud or something right there's no
substitution for there's no substitute
for close
an extended observation right but but at
least four people at the same
institution providing like you know sort
of unified framework for interacting you
know for you know different people at
the institution right to describe their
models right now and you know reduce the
sort of barrier to turning a model a
good experiment know through some
combination of close communication and
and software didn't obvious as low as
possible right so common representation
spurred on not just for Dana but for you
know experimental contacts go through
the you know the design of the
experimental apparatus right its scale
so that it can support more theorists at
once yeah I mean I should say there's
also this idea of the concept of brain
the brain of Salvatori so the idea is
some of the you know some of the
experiments are getting very expensive
kind of heavy in terms of so the ideas
then really to set up an experimental
sites where people can propose
experiment symbol to astronauts who
propose to point a huge telescope so
well and that would also be a little bit
done right yeah yeah so something
something like that right so you know
rather than then trying to solve
communication problems in the past or
assault or globally institutons where
you Pinsir start with I use that ability
this physically co-localization is
important that cannot be all gone over
well or at least you know incentives for
frequent collaboration and you know
where where incentives are aligned right
particularly right like you don't want
to the experimentalists need to be need
to be funded and then you can be able to
publish so whatever whatever whatever
institutions you know physically
co-located or otherwise that enable that
the theorists and experimentalists at
least where the students maybe even with
is their office
so everybody is the same building
everyone sharing and so yeah I think of
this institutional kind of arrangements
are they're nice and supportive but in
the end to make it work one it's also in
sometimes really overriding ideas and
goals for example noise demis hassabis
from google deepmind says not about the
crack intelligence right and this is the
issue which kind of appeals to people
from several disciplines and so I
personally actually I have a hard time
finding to put the results about simply
puts data together puts people together
without a mission or ideas I think it's
really it has to be a potus's driven
goal driven idea preceded I think the
other things are necessary know as a
logistic petrov one has to facilitate
this but one needs to really think about
this ideas and goals and group things
around it yeah so I think Princeton and
again is a good example for you because
there's a focus on the cognitive
computational side is on is on decision
making particularly so rather than
something that's super give you strength
its decision-making and memory and the
interactions of those two working at me
do you
and so what plays are not different
rates different situations where where
there's too many neuroscientists to to
make too much data for Oprah
traditionally the experimentalist didn't
need the theorists I mean it was it's a
very recent thing that the data is
getting so complicated so it's it's a
change and I think we all have to think
okay what would be a put out come down
off this change I think it's an
opportunity for us because they there's
not really data well then quantitatively
to training people so I think it's
really it's kind of data but but I
definitely feel it will a lot at last
ten years of surveys right now really
received happening that even you know
even at NIH they are they I have
programs asking for theory promotes this
has not happened ten years ago so I
think it's just an opportunity also for
us and I think for for everyone so we
define and look at the cognitive science
and stuff
well think of it this way there is
40,000 follicle employees on Sunday
event there's my handle employees and
Hillsboro they're essential
accommodation on architecture was
inspired by McCulloch and Pitt's and the
understanding of the brain seventy years
so they are factoring in addition of
your ascendant they just call themselves
welcome headquarters and welcome and
Intel and everyone and our men are you
sure I mean so some people yes and what
comes out is
something vaguely neuromorphic that sits
in here and the last name
well the day is getting on so any other
burning issues that so maybe you should
have ginger and then start over tomorrow
yeah all right thanks thanks so bright
[Applause]
[Music]